so school is out for the summer and the
wild cats are heading to camp shell like
when i think the show like this i must i
feel like billy must really feel like
summer camp how much fun do you have
filming this season was the best time
ever it was it was so much fun and and
you know obviously i love i love season
one and two but i i would go to say that
season three was one of my favorite
seasons to film just because we got to
be outside so much
um you know at the camp and we filmed at
an actual camp here in california and
obviously it takes place in california
so um it did it felt like real camp it
you know we got to have like the real
camp kid time uh and i know there's a
few people that haven't been to summer
camp before and so like this was their
summer camp experience and
it was it was so much fun and we were
wild and wacky and had picnics at lunch
out in the middle of the field and it
truly felt like summer yeah
that's that's so much fun and like fans
love
ej and gina together so where do we find
them as season three we can get a kiss
before do you think these two how do you
find these two to be perfect for each
other yeah i think uh i you know
obviously at the end of season two uh
the whole season too there's like the
whole on and off again kind of trying to
figure out does she like me does he like
me like what what is that so uh the
beginning of season three you you know
we that you see them start uh together
and they're happy and and uh
i you know i i think there might be um
there might be a little something that
the people are gonna be happy with uh
maybe uh
in the first first episode and and maybe
later on we'll see um but uh it's it's
so much fun and sofia is so amazing and
i love filming with her and uh you know
obviously i got to film a lot with her
this season
um and we have such a good time she's so
goofy i'm so goofy i just love love
goofing off and like trying not to make
each other laugh intakes um
no that's definitely fine we love when
people are working with each other and
talking about your other cast members
olivia
she rose into stardom being this musical
like music superstar and anyways how
incredible has it been seeing her like
go through this transition she's back
for season three as well so how how has
that been seen like on the sidelines as
a friend as a co-star yeah no i i love
olivia so much she's uh she's literally
like a sister to me and so it's so fun
and i feel so proud uh to see her like
blow up and she's you know she she's so
talented on every level she's so amazing
and like she deserves every bit of it um
and it's just so fun you know i got to
go to one of her her concerts here in la
and it was just
so wild seeing all of these people like
freak out for her when she like runs
onto the stage and like it was like a
proud brother moment uh and and it's
yeah i i don't even have the words for
it i'm just i'm very very proud of her
and uh you know it's always so great
getting to see her and especially having
her
that's definitely so much fun and
there's other superstars during this
cast this season for guest role so we
have jojo siwa jessie tyler ferguson how
much fun was it having jojo on on set
because i feel like she was just right
in oh she did there was
like it was like she's been a part of
the show since season one um she's
hilarious um and uh it was a lot of fun
you know i actually got to have like a
very very small little snippet of a
scene with her um
and uh
i just remember in between takes
you know we're kind of at this uh i
don't want to spoil anything but we're
kind of at this this uh
party type thing and uh
and in between takes there's a table
that her and i are standing by and
there's like a bowl of pretzels and in
between takes literally her and i were
like having a competition of stacking
pretzels trying to see who could stack
pretzels the highest and it's just like
i feel like that just like is jojo like
she's so fun and funny and likes to have
a good time and uh she immediately fit
in and felt like a part of the family so
who won stacking the pretzels
well so listen i i was on track to win i
will say and then josh walked over and
blew over my my stack of pretzels so
that jojo could win so i guess josh is
team jojo um
jojo if you're seeing this we're having
another competition and you're not gonna
win so
i know i'm saying okay quick can you see
the ackerman of the show title correctly
save the acronym and the show title
correctly hsn tmts
yes
s
l csl camp shadow leg hey
we did it perfect thank you so much for
everything
have a great day all right we'll see you
later